[Musica]
senza di te Mi manca l'aria Ti amo Ci
apparteniamo Ti amo piccola per questo
ti proteggo Ti amo Sei mia Ti amo da
morire Cosa c'entra l'amore l'amore
romantico che fa sognare che ci rende
unich agli occhi dell'altro e che dà
senso alle nostre giornate con la
violenza l'annullamento l'eliminazione
fisica l'odio rabbioso Da parte di chi
dice d' amarci non si uccide per amore
ma l'amore c'entra per affrontare questo
argomento cominciamo domandandoci cosa
abbiamo imparato cosa impariamo ogni
giorno sull'amore cosa imparano i
bambini e le bambine i ragazzi e le
ragazze Pensate ad un
lucchetto serve a chiudere a proteggere
da attacchi esterni a
sigillare una volta chiuso Non si può
più aprire a meno che non si possegga la
chiave Beh io tutti i giorni per andare
al lavoro passo su un ponte di Roma
bello e famoso pontem Milvio da molti
anni è sommerso da centinaia se non
migliaia di Lucchetti grandi e piccoli
vecchi e nuovi che centinaia se non
migliaia di ragazzi e ragazze attaccano
al ponte per giurarsi amore
eterno Ci si giura amore eterno e si
butta la chiave nel fiume neanche
volendo si potrà sciogliere quella
promessa questa idea di amore è l'idea
di un'unione di una fusione Siamo una
sola cosa ci apparteniamo
Tu sei mia ed ecco che questo amore Si
intreccia perversamente alla violenza Ha
l'idea che sarà assolutamente
impossibile separarsi sottrarsi neanche
volendo potrei mai lasciarmi e il monito
implicito diventa che se non puoi essere
mia non sarai di nessun
altro Ma da dove parte quest'idea di
amore Quando comincio a pensare che sarò
felice se apparterrà a qualcuno quando
qualcuno butterà un lucchetto nel fiume
per me la letteratura scientifica ci
dice presto molto presto Quando nasco
già in culla se sono una bambina gli
adulti mi sussurrerà e utilizzeranno un
tono di voce e delle parole diverse da
quelle che utilizzeranno con il mio
fratellino maschio si chiama Baby Talk e
si diversifica se rivolta a neonati
maschi o a neonate femmine è il modo
spontaneo autentico ancestrale potremmo
dire in cui madri e padri parlano ai
loro neonati Ebbene se sono una neonata
femmina verranno utilizzate tre volte di
più Complimenti che hanno a che fare con
il mio aspetto fisico Sei bellissima Mi
verrà detto le parole verranno
sussurrate in modo dolce Soave verrò
presa in braccio con cura e faranno ad
attenzione a proteggermi ad avvolgermi
Come si fa con ciò che è
fragile se sono neonato maschio invece
mi verrà detto tre volte di più che
bambino forte per farmi un complimento a
mio figlio Flavio l'infermiera disse che
bambino vigoroso il baby Talk cambia
addirittura di tono a seconda se si
parla conn onati maschi o conn onate
femmine sarà più dolce Soave con le
femminucce sarà più rude e più forte con
i
maschietti crescendo a soli 5 anni a
differenza dei miei coetani maschi
smetterò di immaginarmi in posizioni
apicali nella società per ridimensionare
le mie aspettative sul futuro smetterò
di pensarmi
dirigente presidente astronauta per
abbassare i miei sogni le mie
aspettative è il Dreaming up il Dreaming
up è il divario di possibilità che
separa le bambine dal loro potenziale le
bambine a 5 anni già smettono di sognare
di credere di poter raggiungere
qualunque obiettivo i maschi coetani
conservano intatti i loro
sogni addirittura questi tre ricercatori
statunitensi che hanno fatto nel 2017
questa interessante ricerca sull'impatto
degli stereotipi di genere sull'infanzia
ci dicono che a 6 anni le bambine
cominciano a pensare che le femmine non
sono davvero davvero
intelligenti e questa scarsa autostima
li accompagna per tutta la vita e
soprattutto attraverso il loro percorso
di studi Tanto lo sappiamo che sono
davvero poche le ragazze che optano per
le carriere scientifiche le carriere per
le quali comunemente si pensa si debba
avere una mente scientifica sono le
carriere Stem scienze tecnologia
ingegneria matematica carriere
difficilmente intraprese dalle donne che
perseguono invece carriere dove
purtroppo i salari sono più bassi e le
carriere meno solide ma andiamo avanti
il Dreaming Gap ci racconta che esistono
delle barriere culturali che diventano
economiche che negano o impediscono alle
donne di realizzare i propri desideri e
esprimere il proprio
potenziale in adolescenza scoprirò che i
miei stessi genitori a parità di
competenze e abilità vedono mio fratello
più intelligente di me cercano il doppio
delle volte su Google mia figlie grassa
piuttosto che mio figlio è grasso i miei
genitori che mi amano mi rispettano
saranno preoccupati per il mio aspetto
fisico pensando che sarà molto più
influente nella mia vita di quanto lo
sarà per mio fratello maschio di contro
i miei genitori cercheranno il doppio
delle volte su Google Mio figlio è un
genio piuttosto che mia figlia è un
genio dalla ricerca monitor report
condotta nel 2023 nel Regno Unito è
emerso che a 11 anni le bambine prendono
il 20% in meno di paghetta rispetto ai
loro coetani maschi e man mano che si
cresce i coetani maschi arrivano a
prendere il 30% in più di paghetta e con
più regolarità le ragazze per ricevere
denaro imparano che gli devono chiedere
i soldi imparano che più che contare sul
loro stesse devono avere vicino qualcuno
a cui poter chiedere imparano a
dipendere da qualcuno in parole povere e
crescendo quelle bambine anche quando
arrivano a riconoscere le proprie
competenze ad avere un lavoro si
sottostimano pensate che chiedono il 30%
in meno nella fase di negoziazione
contrattuale di un lavoro rispetto a
quanto chiederebbe un loro cutaneo
maschio con gli stessi titoli il 30% in
meno e solo il 12 di loro contratta quel
lavoro a differenza del 50% degli
uomini e così diven tute adulte quelle
bambine imparano non ad amare se stesse
ma a cercare qualcuno da amare degno di
rispetto e fiducia di completa dedizione
Anche a scapito delle proprie passioni e
desideri non credono più tanto in loro
stesse imparano che devono trovare
qualcuno che si occupi di loro e così
imparano a fingere a compiacere a
mentire allontanandosi da se stesse dai
loro desideri dalle loro
capacità Conoscete il mito di Atalanta
Atalanta figlia di yaso fu rinnegata dal
padre perché è femmina Ma cresciuta
sulle montagne diventò la più abile
nella caccia e la più veloce di tutti
era fiera ed orgogliosa delle proprie
capacità ma l'oracolo le prod dise che
con il matrimonio avrebbe perso tutto e
abbandonato ogni abilità allora Atalanta
fiera ed orgogliosa dichiarò che avrebbe
sposato solo che fosse stato in grado di
batterla perché era convinta che non
esistesse nessuno più forte di lei ma
quando arrivò ippomene tutto cambiò
Atalanta si innamorò e decise di
dimenticare se stessa per lui D'altronde
era il suo destino no rinunciare a tutte
le proprie abilità per una donna non è
un male se in può unirsi all'uomo che
ama giusto Atalanta è il perfetto mito
dell dell'amore patriarcale di cui
stiamo parlando che insegna che l'amore
vuol dire per una donna rinunciare a sé
per compiacere qualcun altro prendersene
cura accudirlo sostenere la sua
intelligenza Anche a scapito della
propria è la sindrome di Biancaneve
sposare un principe azzurro essere
scelta anche se non lo si ha
Dopotutto l'amore che ci hanno
raccontato è proprio questo un fulmine
che arriva un sentimento che ci rapisce
che sembra arrivare senza nessuna scelta
senza nessuna azione
attiva in inglese innamorarsi si dice to
Fall in love si cade nell'amore come in
un tombino praticamente non lo si
sceglie ragazze disposte a mettere da
parte le proprie aspirazioni e desideri
a beneficio della relazione con l'uomo
che amano
indubbiamente le donne intrappolate in
una relazione violenta sono quelle
bambine a cui fin dalla prima infanzia è
stato insegnato che dovevano diventare
qualcosa di diverso da loro stesse che
dovevano negare i propri veri sentimenti
per attrarre e compiacere qualcun
altro Permettete che vi dica che l'amore
autentico è un'altra cosa è una
combinazione di cura impegno fiducia
conoscenza rispetto responsabilità e
anche realizzazione di sé e sostegno per
quella
dell'altro laddove c'è violenza non si è
mai amate nessuno può dirsi amorevole se
si comporta in maniera violenta e
l'amore di sé è il fondamento della
capacità di amare prendendo a prestito
una citazione di Forest Gamp potremmo
dire l'amore è ciò che l'amore fa non ti
fa star male non ti fa sentire
inadeguata non ti fa odiare te stessa è
qualcosa che ti libera che ti conforta
che ti fa ridere
dentro ma non ci può essere amore senza
giustizia senza diritti senza pari
opportunità per quelle bambine ritenute
meno forti meno intelligenti solo perché
Femmine allora il legame tra l'amore e
la parte proprio da lì dalla mia dalla
vostra dalla nostra capacità di vedere
che le giovani donne possono amare senza
rinunciare a se stesse e alla propria
Libertà capendo che l'amore è una risata
è libertà e non un lucchetto la cui
chiave è in fondo al
[Applauso]
[Musica]
fiume
n